donc la communiquer est tombé hier Cyril
à 15h02 très précisément en anglaise le
palais de Buckingham nous annoncer que
le prince Harry vous l'avez dit pendant
très longtemps que ça fait pas viadrez
viendrai pas assistera donc bel et bien
au couronnement de son père le 6 mai
prochain c'est donc dans 23 jours très
précisément mais mais sans Mégane
marqueur il viendra seul mais c'est quoi
ça c'est
chaud
sa femme parce que vous savez bon voilà
avec Messi quand elle va au Sénégal elle
vient son homme quoi
ce qui se passe vous savez que
l'ambiance n'est plus vraiment
Harry Mégane que l'on va appeler les ce
sexe puisqu'ils sont Duquet duchesse de
ce sexe et les Windsor puisqu'ils ont
décidé de partir vous en souvenez
c'était sur 2020 c'est depuis il y a eu
révélation il y a eu un documentaire
Netflix il y a eu un livre récemment et
voilà donc ils
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excellent
quand il veut un téléphone lui il hésite
pas il s'appelle Jean-Marie
tu connais un peu les gens ici
Jean-Marie
je commence à me repérer
donc c'est la question
honnêtement j'ai été pour voir personne
j'ai été pour voir un peu
c'est qui se préparait dans la vie et je
peux vous assurer que les choses bougent
parce que
ça c'est hier
que commencer les premières répétitions
les premières répétitions donc c'est
pour ça que j'y allais pour voir un peu
bah déjà être un peu dans l'ambiance
pour amener cette babiole là
pour ramener ce que c'est quoi ça des
grands souvenirs du couronnement c'est
la reproduction quasiment exacte de la
fameuse couronne de Saint-Édouard la
fameuse couronne qu'il va pouvoir
coiffer et qu'il ne coiffera que le jour
avoir une petite te dit en fait
une version miniature la vraie Cyril
pèse 2230 grammes et est en orientation
et
alors c'est très symbolique pourquoi
parce que vous voyez que parce qu'on
appelle des croix Pathé on s'en fout un
peu les quatre croix pater se termine
par l'orbe et une croix voyez et en
réalité lorsqu'il est couronné l'orbe
c'est ça c'est le petit c'est le petit
globe
et lorsqu'il est couronné
l’orbe
et pourquoi y a-t-il une croix parce que
ça veut dire on rappelle que lorsqu'il
est des couronné devient chef d'église
et ça veut simplement dire que c'est le
monde vous voyez le monde c'est
représenté par l'orbe et bien qui est
qui est couronné en quelque sorte par la
croix par Dieu Dieu
qui règne
autorité de Dieu par rapport au monde en
réalité parce que le couronnement se
dire que ça Cyril ça veut simplement que
vous savez que les Anglais le monde
considèrent que Dieu descend sur Terre
on l'abbaye de Westminster pour de
longues Sion ça va durer quatre minutes
précisément et Dieu en quelque sorte
déjà lui-même couronné le roi
[Rires]
qui est d'ailleurs le seul avec le
souverain et l'orfèvre en charge de la
maison royale à pouvoir toucher cette
fameuse couronne de Saint-Étienne et
donc il a quitté 4 Berry pour venir
mettre la couronne bah oui il habite
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
par exemple que les premières
répétitions sont en cours
ça coûte combien cette merde
ça doit faire combien
par contre ça t'a pris une note de
fenêtre tu as pris une note de frais par
contre elle est déjà cassé ton truc hein
diplomatique
non mais c'est normal que les poils de
torche là-dedans là
et donc ça ça se vend bien cette merde
alors oui ça va être un des grands
succès du couronnement avec le mug
évidemment qui va être frappé avec le
visage de Charleroi ça va générer des
millions ça
franchement
mets-moi dans l'histoire
je me suis promis j'ai visité plein de
choses notamment j'ai notamment pu
rentrer à l'intérieur de l'abbaye de
Westminster pour voir un peu les
préparatifs qui sont alors petite
anecdote par le milieu
alors dis donc l'abbaye est terminée à
15 et fermez à 15h parce qu'on est en
train de tout déjà de tout mettre de
tout préparer
que aux abords de ce que l'on va appeler
le maître tel vous savez le maître tel
vous savez pas Cyril mais bon c'est un
hôtel un peu comme ça sur lequel
calme-toi sur lequel ils vont être
déposés tous les régaliens donc tous les
tous les symboles du prix
il y aura la framboise j'adore voilà les
framboises les couronnes les épées les
éperons les 7 et tout cela et bien va
devoir donc accéder à ce maître tel et
on est en train de monter une comment
vous expliquer une rampe une remise
facilité l'accès ce qui veut donc dire
pour qu'il ait plus facile ceux qui veut
donc dire que c'est pas qu'il a
difficile de monter ça que marcher à sac
ce qui veut dire que il va probablement
arriver avec ce que l'on appelle Cyril
en manteau de con ce que vous avez une
quoi très très longue
il a été il a été au cœur du fond de ça
le manteau lui sera assez volumineux et
que les petits pages qui vont devoir
porter son manteau dans notre passé
il est dans sa tenue
et le sceptre dans la main droite ah
d'accord donc il va arriver comme un pas
honnêtement il va pas arriver comme ça
c'est une représentation du Time ce qui
a dit il sera pas comme ça il a préféré
on le sait l'uniforme militaire
mais pour vous dire que les choses
bougent alors sympa lui hier lorsque
j'étais justement au palais de
Buckingham et bien qu'est-ce que j'ai vu
que ils sont en train de faire un peu
des répétitions sur le balcon mais
figurez-vous qu'ils étaient en train de
mesurer le balcon et alors on sait
précisément il va y avoir des croix sur
ce fameux balcon Buckingham ou voilà on
se positionner pour venir saluer la foi
du couronnement alors il sera pas contre
qui s'occupe du vasistas c'est rien il
nourrit les chevaux il sera pas au
balcon tout simplement parce que il
n'est plus membre ok il y aura qui au
balcon parce que la casse personne alors
évidemment le roi le grand frère Camilla
parce qu'on couronne aussi Kamina on ne
cesse de parler de Charles mais c'est le
triomphe de Camille c'était la maîtresse
de Charles à la fois alors on avait dit
au début quand il fait là-bas
[Musique]
absolument il se marie en 2005 et
qu'est-ce qu'on dit oh bien un jour
lorsque Charles sera roi Kamina sera
princesse qu'on sort et vous voyez comme
les choses assez évoluées elle mettra
non seulement même par on sort elle va
être reine tout court
elle portait jusque maintenant ce petit
titre de consort en hommage à Elizabeth
2 c'est une info
il fait une surprise à Kamila
toujours c'est vrai j'ai un copain
anglais de ouf qui est très bien placé
frère il m'a dit que Charles va faire
une surprise il va lui chanter une
chanson il va lui chanter reine de dadju
toi tu es levé
ah c'est parler sur le balcon il fera ça
au bout d'un moment il y a plus les mots
[Applaudissements]
peut-être puisque
c'est mort
puisqu'on parle de musique on peut
peut-être trouver
miams ont été engagés spécialement
réaliser une bande-son parce que vous
avez Cyril en couronnement c'est comme
une super production c'est comme Disney
absolument la BBC 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs
sa femme elle vient toute seule sa femme
elle est chelou
la dernière fois la SMAC
la caméra et on a vu ce qui s'y passe
[Rires]
encore une toute petite dernière
anecdote qui
tu veux on connaît désormais les
véhicules qui vont être empreinte bon
alors on va parler d'une Lada
on va parler du Cacos du Jubilé de Diane
jubilé c'était de coach c'est incroyable
c'est la voiture c'est le carrosse
qu'ils vont emprunter pour partir
ils vont emprunter 2 carottes différents
donc on a bon nous dire qu'il veut un
couronnement simplifier ce sera tout
sauf ça et alors ce carrosse est
incroyable puisque il a été offert à la
reine pour son jubilé de diamant en 2012
il est hyper moderne ça caresse de 3
tonnes à la feuille d'or évidemment mais
qui dispose de tout le confort actuel
donc climatisation
laquelle a été placé une caméra non ce
qui va permettre vraiment de pouvoir
pivoter on va pouvoir vraiment suivre le
parking dedans du roi et de la reine
aborde ce carrosse
donc oui absolument de 2012 et pour le
retour voilà et pour le retour la
voiture qui va être emprunté c'est celle
que l'on vient de voir c'est le Gold
state cool
1761 c'est horrible Cyril de circuler à
son bord Elisabeth 2 disait ce fut un
enfant
vous bougez en réalité dans tous les
sens c'est horrible lui il a de très
gros problèmes de dos ce qui explique
qu'on a réduit le retour pas bon pour
moi
vous savez ce que Élisabeth de disait il
ne faut pas avoir mangé non avant de
monter ah ouais il faut être totalement
à genre sinon tu vas être en or
ou la Boeing en bout de piste avec
forcément 8 chevaux
il faut 8 chevaux pour le tracter
greffe vous savez winds ce sont des
chevaux qui sont l'élevés exprès et
service absolument de la famille royale
ils sont ils sont gré donc gris un peu
gris poussière et voilà elles sont
magnifiques oui chevaux pour le retour
si chevaux pour le départ on commence à
avoir de plus en plus d'éléments il y
aura qui sinon il y aura qui au
couronnement
il y a David Beckham David
on parle de Paul McCartney
Rihanna beaucoup de en revanche en
revanche
éventuellement oui la liste n'est pas
encore
française
tu sais pas trop
donc tu penses qu'il y aura Tom Cruise
c'est sûr donc il y aura Tom Cruise qui
devrait éventuellement présenter mais ça
c'est pour le dimanche hein c'est pas
pour la cérémonie du samedi à personne
mais si si la 2000 invités
c'est des membres de famille royale et
ce sont des représentants des différents
pays
800 personnes de la meuf devant oui il y
aura forcément de la meuf
[Applaudissements]
j'adore oui
bah bravo tu es une bombe